ναμουσίο που μας είχαν καλέσει το νόι νόη μιουζίου καιείδα με τη μια αθουσε που
έγινε τελευταίως από το ίδριμα λειβέντη με διάφορές αρχιότητες από την κύπρο καικαι σημανικές όν
από αρχειότητες υπάμε στην αρχία εκτός από το φυλανθρωπικό έργο είναι και μια πλούσια ηζωή
σας από διάφορες πτυχές ι ζήσατε διπλα από δύο ισχυρούς άντρες της σύγχρονης ιστορίας της
κύπρου και ξεκιναμε από τον πολύκαρπο γιορκάτιπόσοι ήταν ιζωήδιπλα από τον τότε ι σχυρώνο υπουργόνες
σωτερικώ της κυπριακής δημοκράτιας νομίζω ήταν κάτι συναρπαστικό ήταν ο πολύ στανέσανανθωπος πολύ έεύπνοσι χεβεβαιος
τον θαύμασμα για το θασμαζα για όλο το την το γόλο που είχε πέξει στην
στη εόρκα ναόόμως ότιμουν και πολύ μικρι δεαλή ταπαντλευτικα όταν οιμουνδεκά ευτα και είχα το
τον πρωτομο παιδί των κοσταντίνο στα δκαοκτώ επομένος είχα και αλλά ήταν ιζωή μου τελείως
αλλά κάλλος ατεν ωραί ναι σίγουρα και με το πολύ μαστα παντρεμένι πέρι που τρια
χρόνια οι συνέβηκαν τα τατραγικά π συνέβηκαν καιέτσι ήταν μια για μένα μια πραγματικά πολύ
δύσκολύ περίοδος που έζησα μετά το θάνατο του μεταδύομορα τι θυμάστε από την εκείνη τη
μέρα που σα ενημέρωσαν ότι είμασταν όλι ολύ νύχτα υπεριμέναμε δεν ξέγαμε τη